[Music]
I'm not going to say anything very
lengthy you're basically in very good
hands with your conference organizers I
just like to welcome you here on the
behalf of MIT and the laboratory for
computer science for which bob
represents and project Athena which I
represent and actually I really only
have one thing to tell you this
conference will deal with the technical
side of X where X is headed what sorts
of things people are working on to
augment X from project Athena's
perspective there is another side it's
somewhat less interesting from a
technical perspective but for us it's
very important that X not only be an
interesting technical and important
technical development it must also be
something that the industry itself
adopts so that universities can write
applications third-party software
companies can write applications and
that those applications will have a
large hardware base to run against with
that in mind I'm pleased to announce
that concurrent with this conference
there will be a press conference which
will be held it is a non technical
conference and it is a small conference
it's not expected that anyone here will
go over there in fact if you do you will
overwhelm the room it's for the press
only but at that conference a fairly
unique announcement will be made by will
probably be 10 or 11 different computer
manufacturers each of them will
simultaneously announced support for the
X Window System in their product line I
know of no other event quite like it
it's I think a tribute to the people who
developed X that so many manufacturers
are seeking to support it concurrently
as a product I think it is the first
step in seeing a workstation environment
that is less and less machine dependent
and more and more machine independent I
think it's an exciting development let
me just tell you the companies that were
coming to this thing as of yesterday and
I need to be very clear this thing is
changing in very real time
for example if I had made the statement
four weeks ago the number would have
been two but as of yesterday the number
who are putting their name on the press
release that actually went out yesterday
over the wires was Adobe Systems Apollo
computer applix incorporated software
company
Dayna computers data General Corporation
Digital Equipment Corporation
hewlett-packard company mass comp
Siemens Sony Corporation and stellar
computers in addition iBM has announced
support in the form of the academic
information systems 4.2 that was
something they announced today jicama
that they would be providing support
within that part of their operating
system line at IBM they are not coming
to this press announcement today if
asked me to announced that to the press
so what we have basically is twelve
different companies with very distinct
economic interests combining on a common
window system I think you'll hear words
emerging like de facto standard when X
is described in the press not because
that's something we're necessarily
encouraging although I find encouraging
but simply because when that many
companies sign up with such a large
fraction of the workstation market
something very important has happened
and I certainly am quite excited about
it
with that I wish you all have a good
two-day session this should be an
interesting technical conference I'm
going to be back as soon as I possibly
can to what is fundamentally a public
relations event and thank you all for
coming
[Applause]
okay some quick administrivia I want
each of the speakers basically to
introduce themselves we're not going to
waste time with introductions we didn't
get into the agendas email addresses or
phone numbers if the speaker's want to
put that information up or just recite
that information as part of their
opening that would be good we're gonna
be on a very tight schedule today given
the number of speakers we have so please
observe the coffee break times and the
lunch schedule apropos of lunch you've
been given a map the important thing to
note are the places that will handle the
biggest crowds are the student cafeteria
and Walker cafeteria these two places
they're set up to handle large numbers
of students those are the places you
should tend to head for places like
legal seafood will be long waits
typically for lunch although they do
legal in fact does have takeout if
you're interested in that the birds of a
feather sessions tomorrow are gonna
start at 9:30 except for the imaging one
which is going to be at 2:00
I would like to get a brief show of
hands of interest in the individual boss
so can I get a show of hands of how many
people think they're gonna attend the 3d
okay how about the tool kits okay the
protocol okay
window managers Wow
anybody want to volunteer to chair the
window manager session
everybody everybody we asked said no I
won't do it or I'm not coming if
somebody wants to volunteer please see
me
the image is ok if someone we have one
or two extra rooms that we reserved on
the side if someone wants to suggest
boss please write it down and at a break
or at lunch give it to me or leave it at
the registration desk ok I'd like a
brief show of hands that may help the
speakers and I'm sort of curious myself
how many people are here from
universities ok how many people are here
marketing ok how many people here
management ok how many here programmers
right on
well all of the people who claim to have
helped in the success of X past present
and future
stand up be honest come on that's it
come on
not not public domain you know vendors
everybody come on stand up okay I want
to make it clear we've started getting
questions already if you're expecting to
say oh I'd like to get a distribution of
v10 r4 can you please make me a tape
today forget it okay don't even ask if
you're here and you say I really like
five minutes for a demo somewhere forget
it
but I will point out Ralph's Wick
Ralph's wick will Ralph's what stand up
if you're crazy enough you can go try
and talk to him okay fine
good idea so without further ado Jim
Gettys it's going to give you some
status report okay there'll be a lot of
people who probably want to take notes
this is who I am I'm in a transitional
state from here at MIT to the systems
Research Center of Digital Pella in Palo
Alto I've been a digital employee here
in project Athena since the beginning
okay where are we today
basically for version 10 which is
release four out of here the comments
are released four has been out since
December second electronically though
there was an update in late December
with a pile of new stuff as well that
couldn't make the December one the
December one was driven by academic
schedules there's this there's this
embarrassing thing about academia the
calendar year doesn't shift and there's
a lot more device-dependent code on
there a really nice addictive game yet
another read redone version of the
terminal emulator bug fixes and so on
I'm sure we guarantee some new bugs to
boot there are three different toolkits
on there there's one done by rama rao
and smokey wallace at all digital and
then he'll the Packard company has
contributed tool kit called x-ray and
John Auster how did Berkeley has done a
toll call des axe for version 11 we hope
to get back to one common structure and
taking the best ideas out of these three
different toolkits each of them have
their different advantages or
disadvantages what you do with them is
your problem okay but with version 11 we
expect and intend to have one common
tool kit structure to work from in your
notes is also the same basic ordering
information there the tapes cost a
hundred dollars they're half-inch
industry standard 1600 BPI tapes only
the entire format only we do not
generate floppies for anything
and currently I'm told that the the
micro computer center has a three week
backlog from the beginning of the year
okay so that's where version 10 is
release four is the last release based
on we're out of MIT based on version 10
so we go on to version 11 which we went
out for asking for comments on sometime
last summer and there a couple of
specific recommendations I want to make
to to vendors which make it a very large
difference please bother to do the work
for the input mechanism the difference
is dramatic
both deckhand on the RTP see under under
four point two a do the input side right
so you'll be embarrassed if you don't
and a single device for keyboard and
mouse please we want to keep time
sequence order between Mouse events and
keyboard events so implementing separate
devices for keyboard and mouse is a long
term bad idea then another thing which
which came back to bite us 4.3 beta
that's four point three Berkeley
distribution beta has a change in the
TCP transmission strategy which for
example when did its way and ultrix one
point two and may wind its way into
other people's systems in for in the
final four point three Berkeley
distribution there is a socket option to
be able to control the the TCP
transmission strategy and that turns out
to be very important for good Mouse and
we're about tracking and rubber-banding
across the net so I want to point those
two particular implementation details
out as bugs to avoid one point two has
it wrong okay yeah we realized that too
late to get it fixed except on the local
on the local machine so just to know
that this is you know an issue and it
does affect the way we're we're banding
works and so on so sigh such as life
what can I say um thinks that fix the
next release or so I hope I don't speak
for UNIX engineering group but you know
uh okay let's go on to we are very close
to releasing bits for alpha tested
version 11 so what will be on such a
distribution and I'll get to precisely
one very shortly the server will be
almost entirely complete at least in
terms of the protocol there are some
things that we we hope to do having to
do with things like bitmap unders and
and the like which hopefully will make
the beta test version of it but the
server is essentially complete at this
point there is a full set of generic
monochrome bitmap graphics code for a
straight memory frame buffer it's
written to be highly portable it's
written to be highly modular so that you
can plug and unplug pieces will be
people talking this afternoon about the
details of that we do not expect the
device-dependent
interface to change significantly
between alpha and beta modulo you know
bugs that we find that as more more
implementations are done on thee there
should be the the native piece of the of
the X library at least the protocol
native part as some of the additional
stuff like region code this in my
current spec won't make it right then
some demo programs a clock a not a
window manager window manager the person
wants to disclaim any responsibility for
it being a window manager despite the
fact that that's what it is for the time
being and some manuals and porting
documents the beta test stuff is more or
less the same sort of thing but you know
the major major missing pieces in the
Alpha would be things like a terminal
emulator which conversion of the of the
terminal emulator only just started like
10 days ago or something and you know
the miscellaneous tools that exist on
completion of the documentation and all
that sort of good stuff so it's same
sort of thing again attempt of the alpha
test is to to a lot of people to start
doing ports to their devices and give us
feedback as to whether this thing is
real
portable and and whether these the new
facilities work properly okay what you
got to do to be an alpha test site the
deadline for this is February 2nd we
will be asking for a single technical
contact person okay that as we want all
information to go through one person at
a company rather than get random
questions from five or ten places yeah
and somebody's company not a problem
with small companies but any big
companies we see flurries of the same
question asked from five different
directions and in the company so we want
a single contact point on electronic
mail address that as we really can't
deal with with such a turn around time
for for paper mail and the overhead of
making it is way too high so we really
want to be able to talk to all the test
site people via mail electronic mail
where we want to deal with people who
are doing useful and interesting work by
some definition basically that's things
like porting to to hardware and and our
testing particular new features of
version 11 for example people who might
want to build a tiling window manager
which may use lots of new the new
facilities that version 11 provides
there's no good way we can deal with
non-disclosure I mean many of the people
working on the the public server are
Digital employees and we can't sign your
non-disclosure agreements to talk about
your funny hardware right and that would
be also true of MIT employees too so
it's very hard for us to deal with
somebody who can't talk about at all
about their hardware to us okay
at some level because how can we track
down bugs if we can the guy can't tell
us what kind of hardware they're talking
there they're talking about we don't
want to see the the code be
redistributed beyond your organization
and to ask to be a alpha test site you
send mail to that address
I don't have very many minutes
also this is a real deadline by the way
what no you you you'll be informed
whether you'll be an alpha test site but
we must you must get a your request in
by this must be received here by the
second period okay so and we have to
deal with logistics like getting tapes
made and stuff like that so it gets hard
also there has to be turnaround of mail
because we're gonna ask people to sign a
letter saying saying that they're not
gonna redistribute the code basically at
that point okay for beta test it's a
similar deadline it's April 1st we'll be
willing to deal with more people and
with less justification required I am
the same sort of caveats having to do
with a single person and we saw only we
can really deal with people
electronically and the address for this
is X beta
what no beta test time it be possible to
to redistribute and we hope hope and
believe things will be stable enough
that the protocol won't be changing
period at that point though we will
still reserve the right that it may have
to change if something comes up and for
example release one of X was on protocol
version nine which is a very slight
difference from town and mates made a
tremendous difference and portability to
things like the RT PC and various RISC
architecture so ok I've been using
modifications of the slide with time we
aren't doing too badly some people will
see that there the dates aren't as quite
what we started off with last summer but
we aren't too far off I guess we've
claimed in December or January to be
able to start giving out bits and it's
the real date is the 9th of February so
the interesting dates are the deadline
for alpha test applications February 9th
is when we will be cutting tapes you can
expect to see tapes by the end of that
week I believe that that's a Monday and
by that Friday April 1st is the beta
test application deadline and I put a
line here because after this clearly if
there are unexpected problems an alpha
and alpha test then these dates get more
fuzzy but so the statement here has to
do with with a subject which people
who've looked at the version 11 protocol
carefully may may understand and will be
discussed technically later in the day
which is in version 10 there was a whole
pile of different little mechanisms for
things like resize hints names of
windows all those sorts of things we
assume that into a single mechanism and
so there we expect that there will be a
long list of predefined atoms all an
atom is is a nickname for for a string
so for example you can have a resize
hint associated with a window or a name
associated with a window or so on and so
there clearly can be a whole pile of
things in like primary selection
secondary selection whole pile of names
like that so the ones that get built in
we need to know by around then what they
ought to be for various kinds of user
interfaces and various other things
though I believe that at alpha test time
we expect will be like 50 or so
predefined atoms for various things
everybody got this any day signing off
this list jar champine claims that there
will be a way of getting copies of these
slides so if enough people bother him
immediately maybe he'll try to do it and
get it solved the problem sooner rather
than later
okay there are some other information we
need out of people there are lots of
infinite different keyboards in the
world they don't all happen to look like
the digital LK 201 or the or the new IBM
P keyboard which looks very similar okay
so there you may in version 10 there
were no there are lots of spare key
codes but none of them were in the
standard translation tables so you know
you could say that this that this
particular funny key with whatever label
could have a new key code but some other
machine in the world might not know what
that's what translate to okay so we need
to know I mean I'm going around looked
like ten different keyboards okay
and it's clear that if you add 30 or 40
new new codes for different labeled keys
that you end up starting how to have
nearly every key that you'll find in any
keyboard but there may be some funny
heat somebody's got somewhere so we need
a list of descriptions of the labels of
keys which which glyph is written on the
top of the key whether it's you know the
upper or lower position and please send
that information here prevent a lot of
grief
all that sort of stuff I mean you end up
running out of him you you you end up
finding the same kind of label on on
different keyboards so by the time
you've added 50 or 60 more codes what
well good point I said I I'm not I don't
know how to I don't understand enough to
deal with things like like Japanese
keyboards okay I think the statement is
us and and European flavor keyboards
more or less okay yeah
send us the information and we'll see
whether we can figure out what to do
with other funny special cases I think
is the right statement in other words we
free will we will feel free not to
assign a code if we can't figure out how
so that's most of what I have to say and
this is mostly administrivia but we
decided that it would be a good idea to
try to answer it sooner rather than
later to preempt a whole pile of
questions I'm sure it'll generate a lot
of questions we hope that most of the
remaining questions will be answered and
one or more of the talks today
Oh
okay hello everybody my name is Dan
Dyckman I'm from the Harvard School of
Public Health the project I'm working on
is a package for displaying statistical
data using such rendering techniques as
ray tracing and texture mapping I've
really come here just to describe the
user interface I've developed for the
program rather than to talk about the
program itself I think that might be of
more interest to you here's how the
program looks on the screen for regions
let's see how this works now okay for
regions in this window represent four
methods of user interface on the upper
right there's a menu system comprising
three windows here on the left is a
window for test ok how's this is this
okay better
well the light is none it's okay okay
okay on the left over here there's a
window for text input and output on the
lower right is a window which can
contain panels of buttons and on the
lower left is a window for graphical
display let's look at the menu system
menus are hierarchical
okay the menu system is currently not
operational I seem to have lost all
slides okay yeah each menu
okay the menu system is hierarchical and
each menu level is placed in one window
menu items okay as the user moves the
mouse menu items under the mouse are
highlighted a new menu is selected by
clicking with any one of the mouse
buttons my menu manager will report the
selection to the host application which
might respond by running a subroutine or
the application might open a new level
of menu options in the next menu window
here the user asks to load something so
the application responds by opening a
new menu of load options the original
item load well it actually doesn't show
up too well which spawned the second
menu list is highlighted in red so the
user can see where he's coming from on
the screen that's a little easier to see
if the user were to select another item
from that first menu then the second
menu would close up and disappear okay
let's suppose that the user has decided
to load some data the program wants to
know the name of the data file this
brings us to the second type of window
for text input and output this is
relatively straightforward I've just
written a number of functions for
reading keyboard events from the user
and writing text and numbers to the
would to the window formatted in various
ways for instance one thing the
programmer can activate a syntax checker
so that if he wants the user to input a
number then the text manager will do all
the checking for him character by
character illegal characters will just
be ignored won't appear on the screen if
the programmer wants he can light up the
boarder to this window in a bright color
just to alert the user that there's
something to look at why don't I move on
to the third type of window which
implements buttons the programmer
defines individual buttons which
collectively form a panel of buttons you
see one here he can define any number of
panels and then activate one panel and
window when the mass moves over each
button it's highlighted with a red
border you'll be able to see that on
future slides a mouse click selects the
button and the button manager notifies
the host program of the selection if the
programmer wishes he can group together
two or more buttons and make them
alternative options if the button
manager will keep one and only one of
these alternative options highlighted
with a dark border around it you can see
an example here in the lowest row this
is useful if the programmer wants the
user to select from a finite set of
options here I've implemented a color
picker just to show you an example of
what can be done with this the user
selects one of these eight locations the
other buttons in the panel can alter the
color of the selected location by
changing the red green and blue
component of the color or the hue
lightness and saturation of the color
you can change each component up or down
quickly or slowly the buttons on the
right provide more functions such as
moving and blending to demonstrate a
user might increase the red component of
the color okay these slides aren't as
bright as they might be and then he can
copy that red to another location he
might then change its hue gradually or
its color gradually to a yellow keeping
the same saturation and lightness he
might then darken that yellow a bit okay
it does look a little darker when you
see it on the screen and then he might
want to blend the two colors together if
the user then wants the red green blue
numerical values for any color he's
created they can be printed in a text
window note that for some buttons a
function is performed once and only once
when the mask goes down for example the
copying function just copied once for
other buttons a function might be
performed repeatedly as long as the mass
is held down this was used for example
when gradually adjusting the hue from
red to yellow the user clicks down
watches the button change color and he
can release the mass when the value
suits him the fourth type of Windows is
for images
a programmer might use this window to
select objects or polygons drag them
rotate them and the manager for this
window is extremely simple and basically
just reports Mouse events that it gets
from X unlike the other types of Windows
I've described output to this window is
a responsibility of the programmer with
the other windows the managers I've
written take care of all the output
there you have description of my user
interface package so far I found it to
be a very quick programming tool and
I've been able to easily make a few
utilities as separate programs for
example I've pulled out this color
picker as a standalone application I've
also included a panel in it which
displays the color lookup table for the
machine here the user has selected one
of these cells in the color lookup table
and you see the numerical values for the
red green and blue printed out in the
text window another program I wrote will
just continually monitor and report on
the mouse's XY coordinates on the screen
and the coordinates of mouse drags and
if you click on a button the display
window opens up to magnify whatever
portion of the screen is under the mouse
here you see a clock magnified and again
using buttons you can select
magnification level etc as you can see
applications produce with this package
besides being very quick to program are
quite clear and easy to use the
interface is pretty obvious one if you
want to reach me about this you can
reach me at documen that spelled DYC km
am at Harvard harvard.edu are there any
questions
well my feeling about pop-up menus is it
kind of depends on the application you
want to use the hierarchical menu system
I've used is for starters it's just
easier to see when you have the windows
in front of you it's a lot clearer to
understand what's happening if you have
menus that just pop out of anywhere as
as is supported by X Lib sometimes the
users can be very confused which mouse
button do I use to get which menu where
do I have to click to get this popup
menu so I just for a simplicity of user
interface I've kind of avoided making
pop-up menus sorry that might offend
people any other questions
[Applause]
my name is Chris Bergdorf I'm from RAND
Corporation and I'm gonna talk about the
use of oh I'm gonna talk about the use
of X windows in a concurrent processing
environment we've got some papers over
here if anyone wants more information
over the years that ran a lot of works
been done in the area of simulation and
in the last five years or so a lot of
works been done in object-oriented
simulation also incorporating rules into
the object-oriented simulations one of
the problems we've had though with these
big simulations is is that they're too
slow it takes forever to load them on
one machine takes forever to run so
we're working to speed it up through
having more than one processor and
that's what the goals see path system is
which stands for concurrent processing
for advanced simulation we're using X in
the system to build a user interface
both for at the programming level and at
the analyst level who's running a
simulation and examining what's going on
the interface begins at the lowest level
at a rappers level and interfaces
directly with with X in the list we're
using a subset of common list and then
at the high level we've got two tools
and application programs
starting at the lowest level up to the
highest level the rappers layer it's a
direct interface between the X routines
and lists in a 1:1 mapping without the
use of pipes what we do is we convert
seed data structures into lists data
structures and back again on top of the
wrappers layer we have an abbreviation
layer which contains functions that make
calls to X - to manipulate X objects for
example in the case of creating a cursor
we have an X cursor function that you
call that that does everything required
to build a cursor for you and associate
it with a window on top of the
abbreviation layer lies the list window
manager layer and this window manager
similar uwm except it it works only with
Windows created from Lisp and it allows
a user to connect tools or gauges into
Lisp and and then Lisp will manage the
events directly that we have an add
event function that indicates list
window manager I want this this window
created and I want certain events
recognized and upon finding those events
perform certain actions and then we have
a remove event which which allows you to
take out a tool from the window manager
on top of the window level layer we have
on top of the list window manager we
have the window level layer which
contains higher level X utilities built
on top of X primitives including scroll
windows panes color menus and a pic and
stuff for Lisp windows the panes are
merely sub windows that can go on a tool
that that except mouse input an example
of a little simulation we ran a 5
processor simulation using X is it right
here each one of these windows here
pop-up corresponding to the remote
processors in the network and then each
one of these icons correspond to points
that are calculated concurrently
on top of the window level there we've
got the tool layer which contains some
more facilities to support a
multiprocessor programming environment
including that gages package which is
separate from the window manager allows
us you to connect a gauge into this
package and then it's automatically
updated and refreshed and some examples
here of the gauges some example gauges
that we use up in the corner here we've
got a cons activity gauge a heap
utilization gauge and a binary program
space utilization gauge we've also got
an inter processor profiler that allows
you to profile functions and messages
across machines it indicates how many
times each function or message was
called and on what machine it was called
from
okay this is a profile right here at the
top the longest bar up there the green
bar indicate is corresponds to the
function called the most during your
profiling and all the other functions
listed are have a bar relative to the
one most years right here we've got a
side pane that you can't really read it
is blurred but it allows you to scroll
up or down lines half pages or full
pages we've got a color menu right here
and as you scroll through the profiler
everything it's always renormalized so
the top the top listed function is this
all the way everything else is relative
to it
okay we also plan to have a data
structure browsing facility that will be
an object browser inspector that will
display objects attributes and that
objects relationship to other objects in
a window that comes up once the users or
the programmer specifies to monitor that
object and we also plan to have some
menu control of the parameters to that
object from the window oh we've also got
a fancy little pix map editor that
generates Lisp output and it's mouse
controlled and it shows a corresponding
pix map on the screen the actual size
what it will look like
the application layer contains a message
transmission monitor that indicates the
number of messages passed between
objects and machines during simulation
we think this will help a lot with load
balancing to indicate if say there's two
machines that are doing all the
communication we might want to spread
the simulation out and move some objects
over to another machine so so that
there's a balance of communication
between machines not to tie things up
and also in debugging the system and
we're also working on a data flow
analysis browser that will allow
programmers to walk a graphic
representation of the control flow graph
generated by the data flow analyzer
we've got a data flow analyzer and it
generates read and write set of a
program and and the control flow graph
but but the output is really tough to
read it's real cumbersome so using X
we're gonna have a window come up and it
will show a graphic representation and
using this browser user can determine
how to restructure a program to find
more concurrency and also will help
debug a program and get rid of of parts
of the program that say never get called
or never get is because it's not written
correctly
okay so in conclusion currently X is
being used for early development of the
system it is going to be a production
system probably just used inside ran
maybe some other place leaves it but
it's mostly just for our own use it is a
heterogeneous network of workstations
right now we've got Sun workstations and
HP Bobcats over an Ethernet right now
the most processors we have are five but
we're planning on going up to 24 some of
the disadvantages we have with X are as
well as the HP and some implementations
are not the same we have trouble reading
some of our X code that works on the Sun
on the HP and vice versa so it's it's
it's a hassle for us and we'd really
like to see a standard come out if we
could could see it because it'd be a lot
nicer for us ok
I think it's more like the pic smack
level that kind of stuff yeah graphical
output is different that's another
problem we have is our our black and
white pics Maps don't show up on color
monitors they show up on black and white
monitors but they don't show up on color
monitors so if we switch to another
machine that's got a color monitor we
have to change that and that's even
within Sun workstations so it'd be nice
that would work for us it'd also be nice
in the documentation we think to have
some sort of chart that shows how to map
from colors to pixels to pix maps to
tiles and and back again because it took
us a while to figure it out and because
of this and some other difficulties we
had with the documentation we went
through and started from scratch and
rewrote the entire documentation
ourselves for our own use
want yes okay another problem we have
with X is that since we have multiple
machines that we're using we want to use
the network to to hook up those machines
but each one of the net buffer is used
by X is one less that we can use for our
machines so down the line this is going
to pose a problem for us and we figure
we're gonna have to rewrite the remote
login facility in order to do that which
is going to be a lot of work X uses the
net buffers right for Windows X uses a
network yeah okay but we're gonna we
want to use as many as we can we're
gonna we want to have as many as
possible and X is gonna use that so we
need to put in more you don't see with
my boss does eight Meg's
overall though our experience with
access been very positive it's been easy
for us to interface with lists it allows
mouse control from list which is
something that that we could not easily
do from Sun tools or from HP window
it runs on different hardware support it
allows a remote process or such remote
process there to create a window on
another machine and somewhere down the
line we're gonna have it we're gonna
work on getting x-cubed community that's
a remote job some things we'd like to
see and the future is a standard as I
mention before across machines and also
something we'd like to be able if we
could have a mouse input - Emacs
where you can move around the cursor
within Emacs using using the mouse but
all in all we found the X we've had a
very good experience with action we're
very excited about using it more in
future
huh Oh through door - ran units
oh it
well
it doesn't know to be lowercase
oh yeah DARPA
any questions or any other questions
okay thank you
you
[Applause]